yo what's up guys prestige here and i
got an awesome video for you guys this
is a
seed for minecraft xbox and
yay this is a survival island seed it is
called
eskimo or sk actually ask emo since
there are two e's
and ooh skeleton bone let me get that
now this is a pretty awesome seed
because
you're all right you see got it's not
your usual tiny island it's a little bit
slightly larger island
you got your a mother tree that spawns
in and you get an awesome cave system
now this isn't natural spawn
i was messing around with tnt to kill
some zombies but
yeah we got an awesome cave system that
goes throughout the majority of the
island
and also something that's amazing about
this seed
is that it has tons of mushroom biomes
you see has this much more biome here
they're scattered all over their map
they're like
about eight yeah they're eight i'm gonna
say they're eight there are eight
there are eight of these and it's great
so you
all have an unlimited supply of mushroom
stew not really going to have to breed
the cows if you want and unlimited
the cow died why did the cow die
look at this stuff it's
we must honor the fallen cow by slowly
removing his goods
one there one there and one there
one there one there okay we've gone into
the cow
now back to the seed there's some
awesome stuff and if you load notice
top left-hand corner there is a swamp
biome with some extra trees so if you
don't get any saplings which i
will find that very hard to believe with
this giant super mother tree
with like jillions and jillions of
leaves if you don't get any salmons out
you can go
head whoa wrong direction that way that
way that way
that way that way you can go you just
head off this way and you'll
i'll get to the swamp i'm just giving
you guys a little
sneaky pig hair schnicker
we're going like we got we got a little
island piece right there i don't think
that's
i won't consider that an actual mushroom
biomes that has nothing
see we're entering the swamp biome yet
another it's not a mainland but you got
some more islands
here so it's awesome so if you don't
have any stuff or you want to live in a
swamp biome
you just go here and get two awesome
islands
and looks like it has a little bit of
planes with a normal tree
so my name is of the prestige plan i
hope you all enjoyed this make sure to
leave a like comment
favorite subscribe subscribe subscribe
if you're new if you're already
subscribed to know sky blue chicken
and tell tell your friends about this
channel i want to get this note
so that's about it i'm gonna go
hope you all enjoyed this and do what i
told you